ドラゴンボールへ皆知ってるかいベジータがブルマにもと強くなっていく奴って中所
かかる部屋を作ってもらってそこで来なく取りに見せたほうがあるんですよ
伊勢より重力の管理場所で体を動かすって金脈が by された僕が考えたわけなん
ですよ僕の題材は65キロぐらいなんで具材10%ぐらいのお守りを体中にまんべん
なくすることで僕は住宅の博多世界言うなハゲ
知ることができるそうすることなんて日常的な動きをすることだけでも僕の体には
大きな拭かずにその分筋力がつくので一気にトレーニングになるということばっか考え
だけなんですよ
まっっていうふうに今回
[音楽]
手首足首につけるお守りがあるんですけどもそれをほとんど僕の体重と同じくらいの多
さの分解ました彼女にぜんぶつけて日常的にこうと霊夢にするわけですよ
コイツってドラゴンボールディープ12多分な国みたいね地球では22中塾よ僕の体に
かかるわけ
今この想いを体中につけて見栄えの体重だ筋力をちょうだい
しようと思いますであのー危ないです下手すると一発でギックリ腰になるのですの中の
積んできたよね皆さん絶対真似しないようにマジで経過するぜ
じゃあ行きましょう腕上げのなどの国家るって受け続けていただいた
新こわー
まあないといけで一応全部出しましたこれが僕のでやって体重があるということだって
これから立につけていきます
もう
7 oo
俺はああああ
やるらしい力入っないじゃんもういい
いつだってこれカービィ
これがこれがアーチ重力の2枚が張った
いうらじゃないよ
はあああああ
ブーブー言っは
[音楽]
[拍手]
で自分
いきますいきましょうああ
[音楽]
ちょっとパンツでなっています
あ
待ってすごい一致がかかるこれらはこれ
地球とに前の最終のボタンはぁ
ウォーを少しあげるっ
うわああああったそうだ
奪って糞ダサい宿別館美女の地球の2倍の重力を感じておりますが割れて受けますよ
[音楽]
これで受けたい一ついきます
えええええええ
んん
てい分